so let's start with sidecars what do I
mean when I'm talking about the sidecar
model well even before cycars when we
wanted to build common infrastructure
tooling things like logging and tracing
and security tools that we want to run
in every application
we used to have to
either rewrite or perhaps import code
written in the same language as our
application
when we move to Containers we no longer
have to
use the the same language as our
programming language we can put that
common code into containers
and run the same container in every pod
so every pod is instrumented in the same
way
that container is a sidecar container we
call this the sidecar model and it's
been widely used for logging and tracing
and security tooling and service mesh
that's sidecars now let's explain ebpf
the acronym stands for extended Barclay
packet filter but honestly you can
forget that because it does so much more
than packet filtering that the acronym
is really meaningless now
what eppf allows us to do is to
customize the way the kernel behaves we
can make the kernel dynamically
programmable
it's a bit like how JavaScript allows us
to dynamically change the behavior of a
web page
now normally AS application developers
we write our code in user space
and every time our user space
applications want to do anything that
touches Hardware
maybe reading and writing to files or
allocating memory sending Network
messages all these things require some
Hardware interaction
and userspace can't do this for itself
user space apps have to ask the kernel
for assistance in all these activities
we don't normally think about this
because programming languages give us
abstractions so we're unaware that the
kernel is being invoked
now when we use ebpf we can write a
program that runs inside the kernel
that's triggered by an event
and that event could be
any function being triggered it could be
a trace point it could be a network
packet arriving at a certain point in
the networking stack whenever the event
happens our custom evpf program gets run
and
if we attach ebpf programs to different
types of events we can use that to
observe what's happening in the kernel
perhaps even react to those events for
security purposes or networking tooling
in kubernetes our applications are still
running in user space but they're inside
containers inside pods
there's only one kernel per machine or
virtual machine so one kernel per host
and that kernel is shared across all of
the processes all of the containers that
run on that host
as before our applications if they want
to do anything interesting like sending
and receiving networking messages
reading and writing to a file the kernel
is going to be involved
so the kernel is aware and perhaps
involved in everything that's happening
on that host
and if we attach evpf programs to the
right events on the host we can build
tooling that is aware of all of those
applications running in all of our pods
on that host we only have to instrument
the host we don't have to instrument
every single pod
so I've talked about what ebpf is I've
talked about what sidecars are let's
dig in a little bit to some of the
advantages of ebpf over sidecars
for a sidecar container to be aware of
what's happening in a pod it has to run
inside the same namespaces the same
Linux namespaces as the application
and to get it there inside the Pod we
have to have some yaml code
normally that yaml is created
automatically perhaps by an admission
controller or through cicd
but suppose something goes wrong or
there's some misconfiguration if the
yaml doesn't get injected into that pod
the container won't be injected into
that pod there will be no
instrumentation of that pod
and then that pod is not visible the
tooling can't have any influence over
that pod
ebpf doesn't need any app configuration
changes at all because we're loading the
ebpf program into the kernel
and as soon as you attach an ebpf
program to a vet then an event
it's going to be triggered regardless of
whether the Pod was running already you
don't have to restart your pods they're
always going to be triggering those ebpf
events there's no need to reconfigure
your pods you don't even have to restart
them
also ebpf is going to be aware of all
the activity on that node even if it's
malicious activity as well as the
expected activity so tooling can see
malicious processes running on the Node
the sidecar model can also be pretty
wasteful of resources
every pod has to be configured to have
sufficient memory and CPU not just for
the application but also for the sidecar
container and we need to have duplicate
copies of state and configuration
information inside every pod because by
Design pods are isolated from each other
you can only share information using
shared files or network access network
messages
in eppf we have a concept called ebpf
Maps these are data structures that make
it very efficient to share data between
ebpf programs in the kernel and our user
space tooling agents
so
lots of tools have already been written
that take advantage of ebpf and its
power let's look at a couple of examples
from the cncf landscape
the first I'll mention is Pixie this
uses ebpf to collect metrics and all
sorts of different metrics from all the
nodes in your cluster brings them
together and presents them in various
graphical ways this is just one example
of the kind of information you can get
with Pixie it's a flame graph showing
CPU usage across an entire cluster
another observability tool is the Hubble
component of psyllium which gives
visibility into networking information
we can see individual packets and we can
see
the build up of a service map showing
how traffic is Flowing between different
kubernetes services and we also get
metrics information at both layer 3 4
and layer 7 the application layer
Hubble is part of the psyllium project
and psyllium also uses ebpf to provide
efficient networking connectivity
I mentioned that evpf can attach
programs to events in the networking
stack and we can use that to bypass
parts of the stack to deliver packets
much more efficiently within a
kubernetes network
and as well as providing connectivity
psyllium is also providing security
using ebpf
it gives transparent encryption so we
can encrypt traffic between nodes in the
kernel
and we can use ebpf to enforce Network
policy by dropping Network packets that
are out of policy
and about a year ago we added some
additional capabilities to psyllium so
that it can act as a service mesh
sidecarless service mesh
now what's a service mesh a service mesh
provides connectivity between apps at a
service level it abstracts away the
underlying Network and provides
additional features like observability
and security and traffic management
so the Innovation that psyllium
brought to the world of service mesh is
building it without sidecars which we
can do because of the power of ebpf
now
all service meshes use a network proxy
to handle and process traffic at the
application layer layer 7.
and other service meshes have used the
sidecar model for that proxy so there's
a proxy injected into every application
pod
ium's implementation allows us to share
a network proxy across multiple pods
avoiding the sidecar model helps to
avoid the complexity and resource usage
that has often been associated with
configuring the proxy in every single
pod per Kelsey's quote about service
mess
combining this with ebpf also gives us a
much more efficient networking path and
a shorter networking calf means reduced
networking latency
in the sidecar model every single
Network packet has to Traverse the
networking stack multiple times to pass
through that proxy
and if you have
two pods communicating both having a
proxy then the networking path gets
pretty convoluted because it has to pass
through a proxy at both ends
if we run a the proxy outside of the Pod
then we can create a much more direct
networking path between two different
pods only passing through the proxy once
and only passing through the proxy when
it needs to because layer 7 traffic is
involved
and we know from psyllium beta testers
that this ability to avoid the
operational complexity and the improved
latency is really attractive there are
many organizations for whom psychar
based proxies it's just been too high a
price to pay for the functionality that
they get
psyllium was the first to implement
service mesh with outside cars but now
istio has also followed Suite with the
ambient mesh approach
there are some differences in how
psyllium and istio are approaching this
but they're both taking sidecars out of
the equation they both use envoid proxy
to handle the complexity of layer 7.
sidecars have always been an unfortunate
implementation detail
mesh features will move to the
underlying infrastructure at that's from
Matt Klein who originally wrote the
envoy proxy
and with psyllium we've moved a
significant part of that service mesh
functional functionality
into the kernel itself
and we delegate responsibility to the
envoy proxy and uses user space to
handle layer 7 complex processing
this idea of running processing inside
the kernel and delegating complex parts
to user space
has been done before
we're doing it in networking in service
mesh
similar pattern is used by suricata
security tooling which makes security
decisions in user space based on packets
sent to user Space by the kernel using
nfq
or if you plug in a hardware device in
Linux the kernel will call to a user
mode helper typically to help with the
complexities of configuring that device
when the kernel module gets loaded
now in service mesh there might still be
reasons why you do want to co-locate
your proxy inside the pod
if you're running complex custom wasn't
filters in your Envoy proxy you might
want to isolate that proxy from other
pods so you could continue to do that
using the sidecar model
and I think we'll actually see service
meshes offering a range of options for
how the proxy is isolated how many
instances of the proxy exist
the last part of the service mesh puzzle
is encryption
Mutual authentication between
application workloads is a really
important feature for many organizations
let's have a look at how we're handling
that in psyllium using ebpf so I already
mentioned that we support transparent
encryption
traffic that flows between different
nodes gets encrypted in the kernel using
either ipsec or wireguard
and this is has been really great for
many organizations because all traffic
is encrypted and it's very easy to
manage
and you can also use psyllium Network
policy to ensure that the traffic that
flows between different Services is
permitted
but when they're working on a next
generation of encryption Mutual
encryption using application workload
identities
so you can use the identity management
system of your choice spiffy cert
manager whatever else
to manage the identities and the
certificates that represent
each individual application workload
and psyllium will inject those
certificates into the kernel and we'll
use kernel level encryption for
encrypting the traffic
so we've solved a lot of the problems in
service mesh in observability and
security tooling using ebpf does this
mean we will never see sidecars again
I'm sure we will still see some use of
sidecars
first of all ebpf program is essentially
kernel programming so there's a pretty
high barrier to writing ebpf programs
I don't think people will immediately
rewrite all their infrastructure tooling
using ebpf
and certainly
the sidecar model will be a lot easier
for many developers to experiment with
the other reason to use sidecars will be
if you don't have access to the
underlying node
in many managed kubernetes environment
you'll need the cooperation of a cloud
provider if you want to use ebpf based
tooling
but the power and the efficiency of ebpf
means I'm sure we're going to see much
more infrastructure tooling built on
that platform
and one of the real reasons for for that
will be the pull
of users who demand improved performance
and we see proven performance
improvements because of things like
reduce Network latency because we can
run so efficiently in the kernel and
because we can load those ebpf programs
dynamically
so I think the sidecar model still has
its place we will continue to see it
used in some environments but I believe
ebpf has a huge role to play in the
future of infrastructure tooling for
networking for observability and for
security
if you'd like to learn more about evpf
I'll be giving away copies of a book
called what is ebpf that I wrote we'll
be doing that in the networking session
this evening so I hope you'll come and
say hello and we'll we'll get you a copy
of that book
thank you arigato gozaimasu